اجل انه بهذه الخفه بل وتقول شركه ال جي
بانه اخف كمبيوتر محمول في
العالم الهيكل مصنوع من مزيج معدني
المغنيسيوم وهذا ما يمنحه وزنه الخفيف
باقل من كيلوغرام واحد وبالتحديد
9980 جراما خفه الوزن تعد عاملا ضروريا
بالنسبه لمحبي التكنولوجيا بالاخص مع كثره
الاجهزه التي يجب علينا لها يوميا لكن
الهيكل الخارجي هنا هو السبب في خفه وزن
هذا الجهاز وبالوقت ذاته هذه الميزه ايضا
قد توحي للمستخدم بانه قد ينكسر بسهوله
ذكرت الشركه بان الكاميرا الاماميه عاليه
الوضوح لكن واجهنا مشكله عند استخدام
الكاميرا في محادثه عبر سكايب المشكله
تمثلت بان الجزء السفلي لوجهك يظهر بهذا
الشكل والسبب في ذلك يعود لموقع الكاميرا
داخل الكمبيوتر وان اردت الطباعه على لوحه
المفاتيح خلال اجراء مكالمه فيديو فان
اصابعك ستغطي وجهك بتصوير الكاميرا الشركه
توفر اختيار سرعه البروسيسر الذي توده
وفقا للاستخدام المرغوب يمكنك الاختيار
بين معالج اي 5 او اي 7 وحده التخزين او
الهارد ميموري تبلغ 8 جيجا بايت وهو رقم
يعد مقبولا للاستخدام العادي يبلغ حجم
الشاشه 15.6 انشات وبدرجه وضوح عاليه لكن
ان اردت الا يخا ب ظنك بوعد الشركه بمده
شحن تبلغ سبع ساعات يجب عليك ان تقلل من
درجه اضاءه الشاشه لوحه المفاتيح مناسبه
لمن اعتادوا العمل على الكمبيوترات
الشخصيه لن تشعر بالفرق لكن قد ينقصها
لوحه اضاءه خلفيه لتتمكن من العمل في
الظلام الصوت كان جيدا عند استخدامنا
لسماع التي الاستريو الموجودتين على جانبي
الجهاز هنالك ايضا مداخل لليو اس بي واليو
اس بي 3 وشرائح الذاكره المصغره ميني اس
دي كاردز وفي الجانب الاخر هنالك مدخل
لوصله اش دي ام اي ومدخل يو اس بي 3 اخر
هذا عدا عن مدخل لوصله يو اس بي سي التي
تسمح بانتقال المعلومات وشحن الاجهزه
الموصوله بالكمبيوتر في الوقت ذاته بشكل
عام ان كنت تبحث عن جهاز خفيف يمكنه ان
يحل مكان الكمبيوتر الشخصي قد يكون ال جي
جرام هو الجهاز المطلوب لكن تذكروا بانه
ليس مخصصا لعشاق العاب الفيديو المعقده او
للمونتاج الفيلمي الذي يتطلب سعه عاليه
الجهاز يعد خيارا مناسبا لمحبي السفر ولمن
يجب عليهم اداء مهام طويله عبر اجهزه
الكمبيوتر فان هذا الجهاز قد يشكل الحل
الامثل نشكركم على متابعه هذا الفيديو
تابعوا المزيد من هذه الفيديوهات عبر صفحه
تك معبل سيت بموقعنا اربك cnn.com